i think it's cool you know in your story
you're you started writing music when
you were really young right like you're
like 13.
poetry and then that transition into
writing music
okay but then you went ahead and you got
your like ba in communications you said
communications and business and
university
was that you being like i want to go get
this or is that someone in your life
saying before you go chase after your
dream
you got to get this education well i had
a tiger mom
and she kind of forced me to go to
college so
that's why i went she made a really good
point she was like hey i know you want
to do music but
you have no offers right now so while
you're trying to pursue your dream
why don't you occupy occupy your time
you know productively so that's why i
went to
college do you feel like that um
experience in business that education
and business has given you a leg up
in the music business yeah it's made me
a critical thinker
it's just made me a really well-rounded
individual and it's helped me become an
adult
so yeah becoming an adult is a really
interesting transition but college
definitely helped me with it
now your music career seems to be taken
off like a rocket
like we're seeing you everywhere it's
happening so fast
it looks like that from the outside but
does it feel like that to you on the
inside
i don't know this is my third year in
the music game
so um you know i'm grateful that
three years is is happening the way it
does because some people
experience a longer time so but because
it's been three years for me that's a
long time
so um i can feel it and i'm super
grateful for just the journey
yeah and we're looking forward to the
debut album pretty
music is on the way how would you
describe the vibe
um the vibe it's it has a lot of
um bossy songs inspirational songs
turnt songs it's like a memoir of just a
really bossy independent carefree that
is it everything that you've wanted it
to be over all these years of you
prepping for your debut
um i think um
i think it's more i think it's bigger
than what i expected
um it i i don't even know how to
describe it i've
the body of work it's just the texture
of it when i mean the texture it's just
the different sounds but they cohesively
go together and it
makes it a well-rounded body of work
like it's a real body of work it's not
just a whole bunch of
randomly put songs on album
when i'm watching your videos and i'm
watching your
youtube what i see is someone who's like
ready for anything
like prepared and ready for like ready
to go like for example you're
in the video for best friends when it's
like time to go jump off
the cliff in your harness you're like
why do i need a harness
like you're like ready to go is that
your attitude towards everything
yeah if you're with me every day i think
i give my management
for the people who work with me a heart
attack almost every day
i just you know the world is a big
playground to me
and i like to have fun so what was it
like
um collaborating with doji cat on that
um it was such and joy
like we had so much fun with it and the
song's already great but she's great in
person so that made it even better
when they brought you the treatment for
the video like what was your
initial thought were you like was it
wild to you or
are you always like giving me crazier
stuff um i do my treatments
so it's it was collaborative um me and
dave myers worked hard
and we worked through at least three
treatments before we came to that one
but um i'm not the type of person that
can be brought at treatment because i'm
such a control freak
but um so shout out to dave myers for
working with me because i'm super picky
and
my my thought process changed at least
three times
how important is it for you to be able
to be in i mean you just said that
you're a control freak but
is that like how important is it for you
that
whatever you put out there is your
voice is authentic um
well i have to stand behind it and i
think um
music is evolving like i mean music the
perception the brand of music is
evolving to where people want
artists to be really living about what
they're talking about
so it's like because they have instant
access to us through social
media they know if like the song is is
um real or if it's true to our life so
that's why i think it's important so
that's why i try to write songs that
really fit you know my day-to-day
life when your fans are
commenting on videos or on things that
you post on instagram one of the themes
that always comes through was like
they're always like she's so real she
feels like she could be us she's so real
i feel like i could hang out with her is
that a different feeling than you
had growing up idolizing another artist
like when you looked at an artist
growing up did you ever
have something you thought oh i could
hang out with that person that's
important to me because it seems
important to your fans that they feel
that way
um i mean not
really what three girls that i really
wanted to hang out with was destiny's
child
i mean i think that was my experience
because they were so
they were so like they were superstars
but they felt so homegirly like
like i mean i was young as hell so what
i look like being
like a five-year-old six-year-old
hanging out with this job
um but i think i got that feeling
from destiny's child yeah you said
earlier your mom was
very like insistent that you go get that
education
right before the music thing took off
now that the music thing is taking off
what is your family's reaction like is
there anyone in your family that is
looks at what you're doing and it's like
this is wild right now like how far
you've gone in this
short amount of time yeah i mean
you know asians like they
like the the how they see a career is
different from um being in entertainment
but it comes from a place of love and
security so
once they saw me you know prospering and
music they were kind of just like
just super excited and proud of me on
both sides of my family because
i don't know what the statistic is but i
think i think it's like
four four percent of people actually
making entertainment so
i'm definitely a rare percentage
and so part of your you know wanting to
be authentic and take control of your
message is part of that
also there's a small part in your head
that goes you know not very many people
get a chance to do this so you better
do it 100 your own way um
yeah and i don't think it's a matter of
me like
i don't think it's a matter of trying to
be authentic it's just
i don't like it's just me type of thing
um and i feel like what has helped that
vibe
carry on like that is just my reality
series i see life
because i'm don't get me wrong like at
first i used to struggle with social
media i just feel like it was just too
much and i couldn't go live
i couldn't talk to camera almost every
other day and
you know some artists are okay with that
and fans love that but that wasn't my
way of doing it so
i figured out if i do my own reality
series i don't have to talk to camera
but my
fans can still get insight into my life
um you were was it athlete of the year
at your school
when you were growing up how is
preparing for a live show like preparing
for a track meet
um i mean rehearsing
practicing but i think i practiced more
in sports i was the around athlete so i
played track
while ran track played volleyball um and
powder puff
so that's a lot of practicing i don't
think i practice as much
but i definitely would love to because
if i did it will show my shows
um one of the one of the things you did
recently which i love so much
is your interview where you and quavo
are together and you're asking them
all these questions and it's just like
it's fun watching two people that really
enjoy hanging out with each other
what is it like having someone beside
you that knows the ins and outs
of the business um he's really
experienced so
i can come to him asking questions um
it's crazy because he's been out for
like seven years now
and um it's just it's so respectable to
see him
have this consistency and longevity so
he definitely has a lot of insight
what kind of pressure do you put on
yourself to make
this debut and really everything that
you put out there the best it can be
um i work really well under pressure um
so i think that's when my best work kind
of comes through
but i definitely feel like there's a lot
of pressure only because i've been so
consistent from tapping
to pretty rich music freestyle to back
to the streets and now best friend
so i definitely feel like um i have like
this snowball effect
every song i drop i only get bigger so
i definitely work well under pressure
and welcome it
your collaborations have done really
well so far is there someone on your
list that you are
that's like a dream collab that you
haven't reached out to yet
i definitely went on with rihanna she's
just so fly
she's iconic and she's a fashion girl so
i think we look really good in the video
together
agreed now we want to celebrate uh black
excellence this black history month
so we're asking all our celebrity
friends who has been the big influence
on them who they think
represents black excellence um
definitely beyonce i mean her short film
not even short her film black is king is
just so beautiful and it's like you
can't take your eyes off the screen
every moment is a moment the fashion the
dancing her hairstyles
her energy her performance which is so
undeniable so
definitely beyonce between beyonce and
rihanna
you already named two people who have
set like a blueprint
for those to follow like big footsteps
but also big goals
when you consider your career like 10
years down the line
what do you see and what do you want to
accomplish um
i definitely see myself being
a powerhouse um a mogul i feel like i'm
a young mogul already because i'm in
fashion music business and not acting
but definitely a powerhouse
i think my brand is going to house so
many different ventures and
um categories that i'm interested in so
um i'm a businesswoman before i'm an
artist so
that's why i see myself in 10 years
right on that's exciting well hey it was
such a pleasure to talk to you
uh congratulations on everything so far
and i hope to do this again sometime
thank you carlos i hope you're staying
safe out there in canada
you